Silenzio state facendo troppo casino
Così sarò pronto
Benvenuti sono di nuovo io la maestra
ti interessa nella lezione di oggi ci
saranno due tipi di Challenge e se vi
comporterete male le vostre ossa
che la prima Challenge abbia inizio
[Musica]
e come maestra
Scrivi la parola che ho disegnato in
inglese e se sbagli avrai la penitenza
più grossa degli alieni Anche se io
Billy il bullo sono bravissimo Questo
disegno è fatto proprio male
[Musica]
al mio disegno che è fatto male tu sei
sicuro di quello che dici No adesso che
lo vedo bene È proprio una bella banana
questo eh
Oh ma che posso credere
no aspetta aspetta è pronto Come si
scrive banana in inglese benino
beh
Minù si scrive così non è una banana
è una pistola come la pistola non ha
neanche il grilletto come fa a essere
una pistola
mi sono stancata
[Musica]
Ma quella è ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah
[Applauso]
Anita vieni a Lavagna
Allora devo disegnare no no no ho
sbagliato devo scrivere la parola in
inglese di questo disegno
la parola è lips labbra Giusto No sono
dei baffi
dei baffi ma sembravano
Ma qual è la mia penitenza adesso
Questa è la tua penitenza
Ma come Ma quindi vuol dire che mi devo
tenere i baffi per il resto della
lezione Sì Anita Vai a posto
era troppo difficile questo turno
devo scrivere la parola in inglese di
questo disegno
ma non si capisce niente Che cos'è
questo Scusa
quindi vuol dire che tu stai prendendo
in giro il disegno No no io non sto
prendendo in giro il disegno però
davvero non capisco niente Che cos'è
sembra tipo una m con coccodrillo
all'interno
[Musica]
non si vede da lontano
Ahia
Gabbiano Come si scrive che piano in
inglese
[Musica]
gabbiano
è un gabbiano quindi è uno in inglese
Anzi no no ho sbagliato la pronuncia
sghebian
Ho indovinato
era una parrucca
parrucca ora la tua penitenza sarà
metterti la parrucca
[Musica]
come sto
fai proprio schifo E adesso rimane così
a farne a posto grazie
grazie
Come si dice parrucca in inglese
[Musica]
per favore che già hai sbagliato tutto
fatto il disegno
[Musica]
in inglese
benissimo Io magari per farmi una
cortesia non in tedesco
Io capisco quello che c'è adesso lo
scrivo
Country
con la carta ma si scrive con la c di
cane io dico
come quello che cacchio Nutella non è
una candela è un rossetto adesso la tua
punizione sarà mettere il rossetto vieni
qua
Ok vai a posto Non riesco neanche tu
Mi avete stancato
nessuno dei quattro ha studiato anche
quelli che studiavano e adesso passiamo
alla seconda Challenge
in questa Challenge dovrete prendere gli
ingredienti per lo Slime più bello ma Lo
dovrete fare da bendati chi sbaglia
avrà una penitenza
sono qua ecco Ok ok speriamo che mi
capiti un colore bello
Vediamo che colore è
verde
oh papà io non voglio fare lo Slime
verde Uffa
Voglio vedere se il colore che a me
piace proviamo Proviamo Eccolo qua lo
sento proprio questo sono sicuro e
questo qui
bellissimo il rosso rosso e un colore
fortissimo e il colore che preferiscono
insieme aperte chiaramente Chi ha appena
stato fortunato con il rosso Meglio del
verde vediamo a Vitale Cosa capita
adesso
[Musica]
Ok allora
Vorrei riprendere il colore senape come
la mia maglietta
Sì forse posso fare senape
Ok Allora vediamo ne prendo un po'
faccio così e quello che cade
è quello giusto
questo bellissimo
[Musica]
mirtillo
prendi il glitter corri dove sono
Ma dove
Ah dai questa volta Spero che mi capiti
un bel colore
Vediamo che colore è
bellissimo viola viola e verde come
uscirà Spero comunque di vincere la
Challenge
prendi un colore
ancora più bello cerco cerco cerco cerco
cerco Ed eccolo qua
Che meraviglia È un Verde Oro un Verde
Oro Che meraviglia
verde
magari lo scambio con Billy
prendi un colore Sì maestra Dov'è qui la
scatola questo
giallo Allora Celeste puoi cambiarlo
verde per il celeste
no
Certo che tu sei proprio antipatico
Billy Io volevo aiutarti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no no no no no no no
ma io volevo solo aiutarti per l'amico e
adesso la seconda Challenge abbia inizio
via
Anita inizia o Sbrigati
nella ciotola bene allora la ciotola è
qua
provo a chiuderlo ok Sono riuscita a
chiuderlo però devo prendere i glitter
Eccoli qua
spero di averli messi nella ciotola ora
il cucchiaio
qua qua ce l'ho io grazie Ok ora
iniziamo a mescolare no
Ok chissà come sta uscendo Spero che
Erick è bellissimo Davvero è bellissimo
Sì è bellissimo Non vedo l'ora di
vederlo poi Ecco metto un po' di
colorante
con il quadrante Speriamo che vada bene
sporcato tutto
a sporcare un po' di glitter
Ecco qua
cosa avviene senza vedere come girare
tiro tiro giro giro
Clio Ecco glitter e poi dall'altra parte
poi da questa parte poi da questa parte
poi da questa parte tiro giro giro
mettiamo un po' di colorante
[Musica]
grazie
Allora vediamo un po' di glitter Sì
ok perfetto e adesso vi ricordo che
c'era la scatola
Allora Giro Giro giro giro
mi sta mettendo il collutorio fermo
vai va bene Continua allora
e sta venendo bene
maestra Eh non sei tu quello che dice
che vinci Sono io
Volevo solo essere sicuro di fare un
bello Slime tutto qua
Ehi senza benda ora Piano su queste case
puzzolente
così vado
oggi
[Musica]
è sceso è acceso
va bene così
[Musica]
Che brutta ma come brutto è bruttissimo
ma dammi i colori bellissimi ora adesso
i vostri Slime
[Musica]
la maestra distratta Questo è il momento
dello scherzetto di Billy il bullo voi
due colori più brutti verde e vomito e
marrone
È arrivata l'ora di distruggere gli
Slime dei miei compagni
chissà come starò uscendo il mio Slime
Non vedo l'ora di vederlo sono sicuro
che sarà molto bello Poi mi è capitato
un colore dei glitter molto particolari
Se state pensando che cos'è questo
rumore
dove sei Sono qui Dimmi che cosa succede
Ah no niente
che non va Non riesco a capire
se sento come
mi sento osservato
non è che c'è qualcosa
capisco
chi c'è Chi c'è ma che cosa stai dicendo
Stai parlando da solo Sì perché ho
sentito qualcosa vicino Speriamo che
stia uscendo bene
in Svizzera erano bellissimi quelli
Viola Quindi secondo te sta uscendo
Benissimo speriamo di vincere anche
questa Challenge
Così sarò promossa
Uffa ma non si è senza mai questo Slime
Come sta andando ragazzi
credo bene bene sento proprio anche una
cosa molto bella silenzio C'è troppo
rumore tra poco scadrà il tempo avete
finito Sì sì maestra abbiamo quasi 500
[Musica]
Finalmente una cosa sensata
Che strano Billy che dice queste cose
Infatti un po' strano però il mio sarà
il primo
è bellissimo
sì Vediamo il risultato
è bellissimo uh uh bene le piace maestra
Sì finalmente forse dico io Guardi
Guardi che sfumature belle celesti
poi profumo un sacco E certo l'ho fatto
io vedrai maestra che gli altri saranno
molto schifosi rispetto al mio come fai
a saperlo
è un presentimento credo di essere più
bravo
guarda
[Musica]
non è possibile che schifo sembra un
cervello
brutto il mio Slime non me l'aspettavo
così il mio sdraio volevo vincere il
primo premio il tuo Slime io lo chiamerò
cervello disgustoso perché questa cosa
non si può neanche vedere io gli do un
museo spaccato
il mio Slime no allora Vitale
o no
Cosa è successo il mio Slime
fa proprio schifo ma questo non è il mio
giallo senape il colore che avevo scelto
Ma cosa sarà successo non si nemmeno
addensato Ma io non l'avevo fatto così
lo Slime Non so che dire davvero
orribile Comunque ti do due perché è
è bruttissimo Mi dispiace io li sapevo
fare gli Slime non so che cosa sia
successo io lo chiamerò molto di rana
[Musica]
è stato tagliato la benda sì
Ma non è possibile che io ho fatto uno
Slime così schifoso Uh sembra
l'intestino di un mostro che schifo
Comunque il voto è
ma come tre ma io ero bravissimo a fare
gli Slime E io aspetto un momento
vidate ma anche a me è uscito così
schifosa lo Slime Ecco sì effettivamente
è schifoso anche il mio Sì sì anche il
mio schifoso ma non è che
Ma scusa lo Slime di Bill come fa a
essere così bello se il nostro è così
schifoso
bene lo Slime è veramente fatto male
perché non lo sapete fare e quindi vinco
io Va bene
aspetta un momento
ho un'idea controlliamo le tasche di
Billy svuota le tasche subito
[Musica]
cosa sta succedendo qui Ehi schiaffi in
chiave non toccarmi le chiavi le scarpe
e questo
[Musica]
nella tasca di dietro maestra Bigli
aveva questo colorante nella tasca di
dietro e credo che lui abbia sabotato
tutti i nostri Slime
allora lui colpevole perché non si
estrae non hanno funzionato Esatto Che
cosa hai fatto
e non mi avete visto nessuno ha visto
niente perché dite che sono stato io
Salve più scemo tu come ti sei permesso
a rovinare tutti gli Slime il tuo
compleanno
te lo faccio vedere io adesso
avevo fatto niente AH AH AH AH AH AH AH
AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH
AH